hey everybody buenos dias
my name is raymond simpson i am a museum
assistant here in entomology at the
peabody museum
i am a self-professed moth nerd and i am
very interested
in the biodiversity and evolution of
arthropoda specifically
insects
today i am going to show you some of our
spectacular diversity
in butterflies and moths that live in
the neotropics which is
basically from the southern united
states all the way down to argentina in
the new world
most of the specimens are preserved as
dried pin material like
you can see here specimens that are
collected in the wild
are pinned and dried and then labels are
adhered to them and they are put into
the collection for scientists to come in
observe and study so
one of my main passions is
butterflies and moths as you can see the
tropical region of the united
of the new world including central and
south america
has very high insect diversity
lots of like literally tens of thousands
of species of butterflies and moths
which are
scientifically known as lepidoptera
occur in this region
here's a good assemblage of butterflies
called 88 butterflies
they're called 88 butterflies because
the
underside of them have this cool 8 8
pattern
on their hind wing so the top is very
brightly colored
kind of blue and pink the bottom has
this cool
uh modeled 88 pattern or just kind of
cool zigzag black markings on them
so there's several themes
in butterfly and moth diversity in the
tropics besides just diversity
and i'm going to show you some of those
things today
one of the most well-known types of
butterflies in the tropics that you've
probably seen before are called morphos
and morphos are very
spectacular looking and there's numerous
species of morpho
this is one particular species very
common in brazil
but it's found throughout south america
and they're very distinctive and they
have this really beautiful
iridescent pattern and as i angle the
box up
you can see the pattern the hue of the
blue changes in intensity
so each butterfly has wings coated in
very very very tiny scales
that coat the wing and each of those
scales is like a reflector
and it reflects back the blue so if you
look at it under the microscope it's
like a prism
where it reflects different colors but
it's very strongly blue back to our eyes
and the really interesting thing about
these butterflies is make you think like
okay how are they
very adaptive being so brightly colored
but these butterflies use this as in
its ability to basically see each other
as their own species so female
butterflies of the species look like
this and males look like this
that's called sexual dimorphism so a lot
of these butterflies will
use color pattern as a way to recognize
individuals of their
own particular species also
these butterflies aren't always what
they seem
so the underside of a morpho butterfly
is camouflaged so a lot of things in the
tropics will not only use
bright colors to warn predators that
they don't taste good
they also use camouflage to protect
themselves when they're at rest so these
butterflies will sit
kind of like this so i'm going to angle
in the camera where the when the
butterfly's folded up you can only see
this brown part
but when they open up they flash this
really beautiful blue
so they both have the advantage of
camouflage and a flash of bright color
to potentially starve their predators of
a food so these were
these are blue morphos i have another
example of morphos to show you the
diversity
these are actually different species and
these morphos
are from different parts of south
america but it shows the variation
that you can see in the tropics and so
this is a different
color pattern of the blue morpho but a
different species they have a different
wing shape
and this is another species that's very
pearly
and just like the other species i showed
you these morphos also have
a really interesting underside pattern
which offers them
very good camouflage so the next
the next topic i'm going to mention
that's very commonly encountered in the
tropics is something called mimicry
and mimicry is a topic that is kind of
complex
but it's really easy to understand once
you under once you look at it
more closely so these butterflies here
are called heliconian butterflies
and heliconian butterflies have
caterpillars that feed on toxic plants
so when the caterpillars grow up when
they pupate and emerge as
butterflies they will basically inherit
the caterpillar's toxicity from eating
those plants
so when you have these adults flying
around these adults are going to be
toxic to birds and mammals and any other
predators that might want to eat
them so in some cases you actually have
moths
and other insects that'll actually mimic
the um
the pattern of these heliconian
butterflies
so predators basically are tricked into
thinking that
they are distasteful when they really
aren't so you could as
something that doesn't taste
particularly bad you could actually
by using the coloration of a heliconia
and trick predators
into not eating you so this is actually
a really common thing amongst
tropical butterflies and you actually
have these groups of species
it's a really good example of evolution
in action because you have even within a
species
all these different colors so all these
are all the same species of
heliconia and butterfly and these
heliconian butterflies are basically
adapted
to different areas of south america of
different colored
model species so these model species are
different colors so the
mimics become the same color as well and
so over time you have all
these different associated um
butterflies and moths that kind of look
like each other and also change as you
go from say
colombia to brazil so another example of
mimicry we see here
is these are all types of moths
this is an assortment of moths collected
in the tropics
you can see moths are much more diverse
in patterns shape and color
than butterflies are and they're also
more species-rich there's
many tens of thousands more moths than
there are butterflies
pretty much anywhere you go including
the united states so
this species in particular is very
interesting in that
a lot of people might think this is a
wasp this is actually a moth
and this is also this is a type of
baitsian mimicry
which is basically a harmless species
moth mimics a species that's harmful a
wasp
so through evolution you have the
basically the adaptation of the moth to
evolve
clear wings to look like a bee
you can see here it has clear wings you
can see my hands through it
and it has the the really cool like
yellow and black striped pattern
characteristic of wasps
so any predator that sees this in the
wild is going to think twice about
eating it
because it is very it's very much like a
wasp a lot even a lot of human
collectors are fooled by these
as far as like what species
is what and sometimes you have to look
really closely to be able to determine
them my final
box of moths
here is
these are examples of urania which are
actually day flying moths so you might
think
what's the difference between a
butterfly and a moth
a butterfly and a butterfly tends to fly
during the day and a moth at night not
necessarily
that's probably true of 90 of them but
these are good examples of
moths that fly during the day and they
actually mimic swallowtail butterflies
which have these
nice projections called tails they call
them tails and a butterfly
but these moths do a pretty darn good
job of mimicking
a butterfly and the only way you can
really tell is by looking at their
antenna
so and the antenna of this moth doesn't
have a club tip
a ball on the tip of the antenna if
usually butterflies swallowtail
butterflies have that
enlarged antenna tip so they tend to be
easy to tell if you look at the antenna
so between
lots of these butterflies and moths you
have a lot of diversity
in size as well so this is a good
example of a
this is called a white witch and this is
a black witch
you can see based on the scale this is
the largest moth and wingspan in the
world this
white witch moth
and the interesting thing about this is
that the cat the um
the uh caterpillar was only recently
like
i think people had have photographed it
but the caterpillar still remains
undescribed to this day
and if you've seen caterpillars of large
moths
they could be pretty big so it remains
to be seen that
this caterpillar of this butterfly which
this isn't it it's unknown
if you could find the caterpillar of
this butterfly which is going to be or
this moth which is going to be quite big
you can contribute to science so even
within our biggest butterflies and moth
species
there's a lot of work that could be done
by even people
even citizen scientists going out and
studying your local area you can make
contributions to science even
on stuff like this
[Music]